cette vidéo est sponsorisé par panda
kraft c'est les kits éducatif et
créatifs pour les enfants jusqu'à 12 ans
et devinez quoi ils en ont maintenant
sur les enjeux pour la planète et j'ai
un cadeau pour vous je vous raconte tout
ça en fin de vidéo il ya quelques années
en 2016 pour être précis dans une vidéo
sur les maladies du futur je vous avais
dit ça en réalité l'avenir risque de
nous réserver d'autres types d'infection
plus sévère avec la mondialisation et
les progrès des transports les distances
se réduisent nos déplacements sont plus
faciles et ceux des virus et des
bactéries aussi et eux-mêmes évolue et
s'adapte au monde qui les entoure
certaines bactéries deviennent
résistantes aux antibiotiques à cause
d'une trop grande utilisation des
médicaments les antibiotiques c'est pas
automatique et les virus pareil imite ce
qui peut les rendre plus transmissible
plus virulent est plus difficile à
soigner après ebola l'organisation
mondiale de la santé à d'ailleurs
prévenu qu'il était urgent que la
communauté internationale change sa
façon de se préparer aux l'épidémie
futur ctreq est toujours une longueur d
avance sur nous il mute
on n'est pas prêt spoiler contre spoiler
et miroirs incassable effectivement on
n'était pas prêt
d'ailleurs on l'est toujours pas et
pourtant ce qui s'est passé avec le co
vide c'était annoncé par tout un tas
d'experts depuis des décennies et vous
savez ce que tout un tas d'experts
annonce aussi pour l'avenir mais on
écoute pas donc on sera pas prêt les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
en général et les conséquences que tout
ça va avoir sur notre santé succès de
sagan
[Musique]
alors oui bon ok le réchauffement
climatique d'accord même temps moi
j'aime bien ça quand il fait chaud donc
je
vous la connaissez celle là non je suis
sûr que vos lettres j'ai entendu sauf
que vont déjà on parle plus tellement de
réchauffement climatique parce que
effectivement ça donne l'impression que
c'est juste une histoire de température
alors qu'en fait non c'est une histoire
d'augmentation moyenne de la température
c'est vrai mais c'est pas juste ça on
parle pas de météo on parle de climat on
parle de l'augmentation de la
température moyenne à la surface du
globe sur le long terme et on parle
surtout de toutes les conséquences que
ça va avoir donc pour tenir compte de
tout ça on parle plutôt de changement
climatique et même de dérèglement
climatique parce que ça apporte deux
notions supplémentaires un changement ça
peut être positif sauf que là c'est loin
d'être le cas hélas et puis un
changement ça peut être naturel ça peut
être une évolution normale ça fait des
millions d'années qu'on alterne entre
eux les phases de refroidissement et les
phases de réchauffement sauf que là pas
du tout le réchauffement on observe déjà
et qui va se poursuivre il a rien de
naturel il ya des coupables et on les
connaît bien vu que c'est nous le
changement du climat il et anthropiques
il est lié aux activités humaines on à
dérégler le climat on va pas
complètement rentré dans les détails du
dérèglement climatique parce que c'est
pas complètement le sujet aujourd'hui
mais je vous mets des liens dans la
description de la vidéo vous irez voir
si ça vous intéresse de vous renseigner
et puis on va voir quand même un ou deux
trucs pour savoir de quoi on parle
exactement il ya plusieurs causes au
dérèglement climatique mais la
principale c'est l'effet de serre en
gros les rayons du soleil ils sont
projetés sur la surface de la terre qui
absorbe une partie de l'énergie aie qui
en réfléchi une autre qui repart d'où
elle vient mais dans l'atmosphère il ya
certains gaz les fameux gaz à effet de
serre qui empêche une partie de ce
rayonnement de repartir donc ils restent
là et par différents mécanismes ça fait
monter la température un peu comme sous
une serre où le nom
ces gaz on les connaît on a tout un
paquet comme la vapeur d'eau par exemple
mais les deux gaz à effet de serre qui
sont les plus émis par l'homme c'est le
méthane et surtout le dioxyde de carbone
oui le dioxyde de carbone comme dans
empreinte carbone reconnaissez dans
aussi le co2 ou le gaz carbonique bref
ces gaz sont présents à l'état normal
dans l'atmosphère mais ils sont en
constante augmentation depuis le 19e
siècle leurs émissions elles ont explosé
principalement parce qu on crame de plus
en plus de pétrole de gaz et de charbon
l'énergie fossile suis sûr que vous avez
entendu par l'état et par ailleurs au
niveau des activités humaines les plus
nuisibles on à la déforestation
l'agriculture intensive et notamment
l'élevage sont d'ailleurs responsables
d'une bonne partie de la déforestation
et puis aussi certaines industries les
transports etc bref vous avez compris où
je veux en venir quand on voit les
causes en question on se dit quand même
que c'est pas gagné parce que c'est pas
comme si on sentait une vraie volonté de
se passer tout ça et pourtant il va bien
falloir parce qu'on a déjà pris 1,1
degré en moyenne depuis la fin d'une
alliance iag et c'est pas fini en 2015
l'objectif des gouvernements s'étaient
de limiter le réchauffement à 1,5 degré
c'était dans les accords de paris sur le
climat qui ont été signés par presque
200 pays sauf la chine et les états unis
c'est à dire les deux plus gros
émetteurs de gaz à effet de serre du
monde alors depuis ils ont signé les
fameuses accord mais vous allez voir
qu'on a pas le cul sorti des ronces mais
parce que gagner plusieurs degrés comme
ça ça va pas juste vous permettre de
faire des économies sur les pulls ça va
avoir tout un tas de conséquence et ça
va notamment avoir tout un tas de
conséquences directes et indirectes sur
votre santé en février dernier le giec a
rendu son dernier rapport alors le giec
c'est le groupe intergouvernemental
d'experts sur l'évolution du climat
c'est des scientifiques du monde entier
qui étudient qui synthétise toutes les
dernières connaissances sur le climat
ces changements et leurs conséquences et
qui met tout ça dans des rapports pour
aider les gouvernements à prendre leurs
décisions en matière de lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique c'est notamment
ce qu'on fixe et le fameux seuil des 1,5
degrés de réchauffement à ne pas
dépasser sous peine de conséquences
dramatiques et dans leur dernier rapport
dont qu'ils estiment que les mesures qui
ont été prises jusqu'à maintenant ne
permettront pas d'atteindre cet objectif
et compare plutôt sur un 3,2 degrés de
réchauffement d'ici là
et ça n'est pas une bonne nouvelle ils
ont même d'identifier 127 truc vraiment
important qui risque de nous tomber
dessus si on change pas ça et puis y'a
aussi l' oms l'organisation mondiale de
la santé qui a dit que ok peut-être que
l'augmentation des températures ça
allait avoir un ou deux effets positifs
genre dans certaines régions il y aura
moins de morts l'hiver puis dans
certaines autres régions ce sera plus
facile de cultiver certains trucs mais
globalement la balance elle est négative
et le coût humain risque d'être très
élevé parce que le dérèglement
climatique c'est pas juste des degrés en
plus c'est aussi des phénomènes
météorologiques extrêmes un catastrophe
naturelle si vous voulez de plus en plus
fréquentes elles ont déjà triplé depuis
les années 60 et c'est pas fini et là on
parle de tempête le cyclone de pluies
torrentielles d'inondations
on parle de sécheresse
on parle de canicule on parle d'
incendies etc et pour l'instant les pays
qui en souffre le plus parce que oui ça
a déjà commencé
c'est pas des pays européens mais à
terme tout le monde va être touché alors
les catastrophes naturelles elle tue sur
le moment quand elle arrive évidemment
mais là comme en plus elles vont se
répéter elles vont avoir des
conséquences sur le long terme sur la
qualité de l'air la qualité de l'eau et
sur celle des terres cultivables par
exemple l'agriculture et l'élevage ça va
devenir impossible dans certaines zones
et l'accès à l'eau potable ça va se
compliquer sérieusement le nombre de
personnes touchées par la famine ils
pourraient flamber sachant qu'il était
de 690 millions en 2019 et qu'il avait
déjà augmenté de 60 millions en cinq ans
on va aussi avoir de plus en plus de
maladies liées aux problèmes d'eau comme
les diarrhées par exemple sachant que ça
tu déjà plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'enfants chaque année et puis dans un
autre gît ça va aussi provoquer
l'augmentation des prix de certains
produits alimentaires qu'ils vont
devenir plus rare et ça ça va toucher
tous les consommateurs les vagues de
chaleur les canicules des sécheresses
etc elles vont se multiplier aussi et là
en plus des enfants il ya les personnes
âgées qui vont être particulièrement
touchés parce qu'ils sont très très
vulnérable à tous les problèmes liés à
la déshydratation les inondations
qu'elles soient liées aux intempéries ou
à la montée du niveau des océans sur les
littoraux ça va ravager d'immenses
surfaces habitables l'humidité est aussi
la chaleur ça va favoriser le
développement de l'arve et de moustiques
qui trimballe et du coup qui
transmettent tout un tas de maladies
comme le paludisme
le chikungunya six cas la dengue et j'en
passe donc les conséquences elles font
frapper directement la santé des gens
qui vivent dans les zones touchées et ça
va aussi forcé des populations entières
à aller vivre ailleurs ce qu'on appelle
les déplacés climatiques les
déplacements de population ça pose
plusieurs problèmes et notamment un qui
est celui de mettre les gens en contact
avec une nouvelle fois à laquelle il
n'était pas habitué et ça c'est les
conditions idéales pour la transmission
de nouveaux virus d'une espèce à une
autre donc à l'humain c'est ce qu'on
appelle une zoonose et c'est le point de
départ pour de nouvelles épidémies et de
nouvelles pandémies et je vous parle
même pas de la fonte du permafrost qui
en plus de relâcher plein de méthane et
vieux type de carbone dans l'atmosphère
va libérer des virus certains vieux de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'années
et qui sont restés bien à la bouche dans
la glace donc qu'ils sont toujours
actifs et pareil pour un certain nombre
de bactéries et tout ce petit monde
pourrait très bien finir par contaminer
des espèces animales y compris les
humains les experts de libet ce qui sont
un peu le giec de la biodiversité
ils ont d'ailleurs prévenu dans un
rapport en 2020 que des pandémies
futures vont apparaître plus souvent se
propageront plus rapidement causeront
plus de dommages à l'économie mondiale
et tueront plus de personnes que le
comique 19 si rien n'est fait parce que
oui la biodiversité va aussi souffrir du
dérèglement climatique le rapport de
l'icg baisse prévient que si des
décisions très fortes ne sont pas prises
c'est une véritable aire des pandémies
qui pourrait voir le jour dans les
années qui viennent et ça j'en ai déjà
parlé dans une vidéo du vortex d'arte et
que je vous invite à aller voir il ya
déjà pour la première fois une espèce de
mammifère qui s'est éteinte
officiellement à cause du dérèglement
climatique ces terres en 2016 avec le
mélo miss rue micola qui est une sorte
de petit rongeur qui vivaient sur une
île au large de l'australie voilà lui
c'est la montée du niveau des océans qui
l'a fait disparaître mais c'est pas le
seul problème avec les océans ne
deviennent de plus en plus acides le co2
encore les coraux qui ont déjà pas mal
morflé et qui sont super important il
pourrait ne pas réussir à s'adapter à ça
et pareil pour tout un tas d'autres
espèces en fait genre celle qu un
squelette ou une coquille en calcaire
par exemple parce que de l'acide sur du
calcaire sais pas où tu joues au niveau
global c'est-à-dire pas que dans les
océans un tiers des espèces pourraient
disparaître d'ici 2070 je vous laisse
imaginer les conséquences pour
l'équilibré des écosystèmes
d'autant que la flore a déjà commencé a
bien morflé aussi donc si on résume
pauvreté famine maladies liées à l'eau
déplacements de populations virus
pandémie maladies gastro intestinales
sans parler des maladies
cardiovasculaires et respiratoires et
des allergies
les experts estiment qu'elle pourrait
augmenter aussi pour une raison très
simple elles sont aggravées par la
chaleur et par la baisse de qualité de
l'air et puis aussi la question de
l'exposition aux uv qui est pas encore
complètement tranché mais sur laquelle
les scientifiques commencent à se
pencher ça joue entre des cancers de la
peau notamment si elles augmentent et
des déficit en vitamine d est nécessaire
pour la fixation du calcium sur les os
si elle diminue et tout ça c'est juste
les conséquences directes ou indirectes
prévisible sur la santé physique mais il
ya tout ce qui n'est pas prévisible déjà
et puis vous le savez si vous êtes des
habitués la santé ça n'est pas que la
santé physique
donc il faut bien garder à l'esprit que
tout ce dont on a parlé ça va aussi
avoir des conséquences sur la santé
mentale
y a qu'à regarder ce que deux ans pour
des miss a provoqué déjà là on parle de
stress d'anxiété d'angoise de troubles
psychiatriques qui vont être liés aux
catastrophes naturelles et aux
situations de crises sanitaires qui sont
amenés à se multiplier mais qui vont
aussi découler des conflits et de la
violence qui seront liés à la précarité
et les pénuries et c'est le dérèglement
climatique
il va s'attaquer à tout ce qui est
nécessaire à notre santé la qualité de
l'air la qualité de l'eau la quantité de
nourriture disponible
nos logements notre sécurité notamment
sanitaires etc et le giec regrette que
les mesures qui sont prises soient court
termiste et qu'elle arrive parfois trop
tard parce que oui certains effets du
dérèglement
atik sont déjà irréversibles mais ça
veut pas dire qu'il ya plus rien à faire
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut tout laisser
tomber et ferment au contraire les
experts estiment qu'on peut encore
contenir le réchauffement sous la barre
fatidique des 5 degrés donc limiter ses
effets de futures d'un côté et d'un
autre côté qu'on peut aussi s'adapter
aux changements qui vont arriver quand
même du coup mais qui seront gérables
mais là dessus aussi en termes de
mesures pour s'adapter aux changements
on a encore pas mal de boulot di donc on
a une belle marge de progression si vous
voulez vu les causes du phénomène on a
bien compris que tout ça ça va passer
par des changements radicaux des
changements qui concerne les énergies
fossiles les modes d'agriculture et
d'élevage donc notre mode d'alimentation
les activités industrielles les
transports etc des changements qui vont
avoir des gros impact sur l'économie et
même sur notre modèle économique et donc
qu'ils vont devoir passer par des
décisions fortes des états des
industriels etc mais évidemment nous
aussi on a notre rôle à jouer là-dedans
en votant déjà et puis en changeant nos
habitudes de consommation et même nos
habitudes de vie on peut impulser le
changement mais il faut que tout le
monde s'y mettre deux notes positives
pour finir quand même d'abord en
changeant nos habitudes pour limiter
notre impact sur l'environnement et sur
le climat on va déjà commencer à
améliorer notre santé en marchant ou en
prenant le vélo plutôt qu'un moyen de
transport qui émet du co2 à chaque fois
qu'on peut on va faire de l'exercice
physique en limitant notre consommation
de viande est surtout due aux rouges on
va faire chuter notre risque de cancer
colorectal globalement en portant une
plus grande attention à ce qu'on mange à
sa provenance etc on va prendre des
meilleures habitudes alimentaires aussi
mais bon vu que soyons pas naïfs le nerf
de la guerre ça va être l'argent
deuxième point positif certains
économistes estiment que le passage à un
modèle moins émetteurs en co2
permettrait de générer 26 mille
milliards de dollars de gains
économiques supplémentaires d'ici 2030
et de créer 65 millions d'emplois voilà
en attendant la prochaine conférence sur
le climat s'est en egypte en novembre
2022 pop attendait bougez pas je vous
vois rester là j'ai pas fini je voulais
dit au début ces vidéos elle est
sponsorisée par panda kraft et je vous
ai dit aussi que j'allais vous expliquer
et que j'avais un cadeau alors resté
jusqu'au bout d'abord je vous hais pique
et après je vous parle du cadeau c'est
du chantage mais c'est pour votre bien
c'est pour votre bien parce que les
générations précédentes et les nôtres on
vient de le voir on a bien vouziers la
planète la bonne nouvelle c'est que la
relève est là et qui peuvent encore
sauver les meubles pendant la grave qui
font des kits éducatif et créatif pour
eux justement pour les enfants jusqu'à
12 ans ça fonctionne par abonnement ça
coûte 10 euros par mois c'est avec ou
sans engagement et vous recevez un kit
différents tous les mois adaptés à l'âge
de l'enfant explore pour les 3 à 7 ans
et maker's pour les 8 à 12 ans dans ces
kits ya un magazine éducatif avec plein
d'infos intéressantes et une activité
manuelle à faire soi même un truc à
fabriquer regardez on voit tout de suite
que je suis plus éveillés c'est sur une
thématique différente à chaque fois et
là on rentre dans le cycle waouh ma
planète ils font ça tous les ans le but
c'est de sensibiliser les enfants à la
beauté de la planète et de leur
apprendre à agir pour la protéger en mai
ce sera des activités autour de
l'importance de manger sainement tout en
respectant l'environnement avec des
fruits et des légumes a planté en juin
ce sera sur le grill avec de l'adn de
singe pour fabriquer son propre animal
bien sûr que non ce sera des infos sur
les menaces qui pèse sur l'espèce et un
gorille à fabriquer mais en carton bien
sûr hélas pour le mois d'avril si vous
regardez cette vidéo en avril c'est sur
les enjeux pour sauver la planète avec
des vrais défis concrets à réaliser tout
seul ou en famille ou avec ses potes
pour y arriver avec une planète à
fabriquer un globe terrestre on se
comprend donc si vous êtes dans la team
darron ou d'armes ou si vous avez des
enfants dans votre entourage ou si vous
êtes vous même un enfant avec une
conscience écolo et un pouvoir d'achat
ma pitié sauvez-nous aller sur le site
de prendre à kraft et aux frais des kits
aux jeunes pour leur apprendre à réparer
nos erreurs et puis après si vous voulez
les mois suivants il y aura d'autres
thèmes il y aura le cerveau en septembre
et les illusions d'optique en octobre
par exemple mais mon cadeau à moi et on
y vient y concerne wamu ma planète je
vous offre 30% de réduction avec le code
dans ton corps tout attaché non il faut
pas écrire tout attaché alors c'est
juste dans ton corps c'est écrit là je
vous mets toutes les infos dans la
description de la vidéo allez-y sauver
la planète en faisant plaisir à un
enfant et n'oubliez pas le code promo il
est valable jusqu'au 19 avril
il voit la dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo d'ici là prenez soin de vous
prenez soin des autres et prenez soin de
la planète mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]